a last-minute settlement has been
negotiated by four defendants to head
off a landmark federal trial against
opioid manufacturers and distributors
the deal reportedly will cost those
companies that combined two hundred and
sixty million dollars the walgreens
drugstore chain still faces trial at a
later date unless it joins that
settlement this case is the first to
proceed of the many lawsuits filed by
local governments over the opioid crisis
that's killed about four hundred
thousand Americans since 1999 Adriana
Diaz is outside the federal courthouse
in Cleveland Adriana what's the latest
news of this settlement broke just over
an hour before opening statements were
supposed to start now this federal case
in Ohio was supposed to be a litmus test
for more than two thousand other cases
that are currently pending this
settlement may encourage those cases to
settle as well or they may move forward
to trial depending on how the walgreens
child goes either way the nation is
watching closely including a West
Virginia family that we met that has
been it devastated by the opioid
epidemic I feel like we have been
forgotten
we need a harvey never thought she'd
spend her retirement years raising young
children but around a decade ago she
became a mother again twice over their
love of my life I think for me my
biggest fear is what if they have to
have pain medication and we'll it tipped
him over into being addicted you don't
want what happened to their mother to
happen to him no Juanita and her husband
adopted their grandchildren Emily and
Jeremiah because of their birth mother's
addiction which Juanita says started
when a doctor prescribed her opioids
after a car accident
Juanita told us the children were born
addicted to drugs she was warm I liked
Beckley it's a pretty town yeah it has a
lot of drug problems really like too
many like worse than New York growing in
other states how do you know that used
the Harvey's live in Beckley West
Virginia hard hit by the opioid epidemic
West Virginia has had more opioid
related deaths than any other state
followed by neighboring Ohio
the Harvey's are now part of a class
action lawsuit against opioid
distributors manufacturers and retail
pharmacies accusing them of aggressively
marketing distributing and over
prescribing the drugs Steven knew is the
Harvey family attorney
he's closely watching the federal case
involving summit and Cuyahoga counties
in Ohio in the courtroom everyone's
equal a family like the Harvey family or
a county like Cuyahoga County stands on
equal footing with multinational
billion-dollar corporations and numbers
that are at stake are enormous New York
attorney Harland Levy says the Ohio
federal case is known as a bellwether
trial which will set the groundwork for
around 2,500 similar cases across the
country but it's not the first time
recently that a major corporation has
been taken to task in August drugmaker
Johnson & Johnson was ordered to pay
more than 572 million dollars after
being found liable in state court for
helping fuel Oklahoma's opioid crisis
they are appealing that decision this is
entirely new ground this is the
reckoning for the opioid crisis a
reckoning is exactly what Juanita Harvey
wants perhaps forever changed not only
birth mom's grandparents but the
children the children's lives are
forever change although most of the
defendants in this federal case in Ohio
have settled Walgreens did not and the
judge said today that a trial date will
be set for the future for Walgreens now
still pending are thousands of other
cases being brought by local governments
and Native American tribes against these
drug companies as well as the class
action lawsuit on behalf of families
that the Harvey's are part of we'll be
watching that trial closely Adriana
thank you very much